donc l'aspect sympathique de la police
ce soir mais il ya un aspect moins
flatteur un cas heureusement rarissime
mais qui va sans doute vous faire bondir
j'appellerais ça
la vieille dame et les trois policiers
indigne il s'agit d'une histoire qui est
arrivée il ya trois semaines à athis
mons près de paris une dame de 89 ans a
été agressée par trois policiers en
uniforme qui ont volé ses économies
douze mille francs et ses bijoux
elle a cru qu'il s'agissait de faux
policiers et c'est pratiquement une
équipe d'antenne 2 qui lui a appris ce
matin qu'ils étaient bien vrai un fait
divers qui s'est passé près d'orly dans
la banlieue parisienne trois gardiens de
la paix avaient profité d'une visite
dite de sécurité nocturne pour dévaliser
une personne âgée chez elle pour cent
même l'inconscience a laissé le fourgon
à quelques mètres du pavillon où il
opérait
après une longue enquête deux des
gardiens de la paix ont été arrêtés le
troisième en vacances à la martinique
fait l'objet d'un mandat d'amener
j'ai hurlé magique trier alors il m'a
mis une serviette dans la cai avait lui
à drogue
il manie femme craque sur la figure et
ils ont dit que je dormais quand il
était venu c'est intimement foutu la
drogue et mans series que l'âge madame
et vous avez quel âge j'ai près de 90
ans
alors vous vous rendez compte alors je
me le demande c'est que fait la police
et bien maman justement tu ne devinerais
jamais qu'il a tant brillé
la dernière fois qu'ils se sont trois
policiers du commissariat d'athis ils
sont arrêtés
ce sont les policiers qui manquent en
brionnais nous ne sommes parvenus
ces ombres de richard et c'est pas pour
eux
une autre affaire il y a quelques mois
avait fait parler du commissariat
d'athis mons dans les journaux un
gardien de la paix avait tiré sur un
mineur prétendant que le jeune homme le
menacé d'un couteau il n'en était rien
et le couteau en question c'était celui
du policier
il ne faudrait pas que cette bavure
rejaillit sur l'ensemble des gardiens de
la paix chaque profession compte dans
ses rangs des brebis galeuses mais
l'opinion publique n'accepte pas que des
hommes en uniforme se transforme en
gangster cet uniforme donne des droits
aux policiers mais aussi des devoirs et
des responsabilités
aujourd'hui après l'inculpation des
agents agresseurs la fédération autonome
des syndicats de police à déplorer et
condamner l'acte commis à athis mons
mais cette fédération dénonce aussi
l'insuffisance de la formation ainsi que
les mauvaises conditions de recrutement
du personnel alors qu'en angleterre on
met des années à former un policier en
france le stage ne dure que six mois les
gardiens de la paix qui font bien leur
métier
non sans doute que plus de mérite
[Musique]